bonne nouvelle très bonne nouvelle pour
la france le groupe vient de réaliser
quelques 2 milliards de francs de
bénéfice sur l'année commerciale 2000
2001 c'est la seule compagnie au monde à
réaliser une telle performance
l'une des raisons de cette réussite
vient de la mise en place d'une
plate-forme de correspondance à roissy 1
appelle ça en anglais un hub hb mais
pour autant air france se veut prudent
pour les mois à venir commentaires ses
fans des pinault avec dominique bonnet à
chaque atterrissage le compte à rebours
est déclenché pour les agents d'air
france pas une minute à perdre les
passagers en correspondance immédiate
ont droit à un traitement de faveur ils
sont accueillis dès leur sortie de
l'avion ce matin un client en provenance
de budapest et à destination la
californie comme ses passagers un temps
de correspondance très court et n'est
absolument plus autonome votre sa
correspondance nous intervenons nous
envoyons un voltigeur avec un véhicule
qui récupère le client à l'arrivée et ne
transfère directement 20 ans très court
c'est le principe du hub concentraient
le maximum de vols dans un minimum de
temps pour multiplier les
correspondances l'aéroport de roissy
joue ainsi le rôle d'une pompe aspirante
pour la compagnie nous offrons puis le
casting possibilités de correspondances
chaque semaine en moins de deux heures
ainsi que par exemple sur la kxf france
etats unis où notre part de marché était
inférieure à 30% avant la création
bob aujourd'hui nous jouons à parts
égales avec les transporter plus de la
moitié de la clientèle d'air france est
désormais internationale il faut dire
que l'image de la compagnie a bien
changé autrefois réputé pour ses grèves
à présent allié à delta airlines elle
est reconnue pour sa qualité de service
les billets sont moins chers et je pense
que la cuisine française les meilleurs
pendant ce temps notre passager pour los
angeles ne s'occupe de rien et sur la
piste c'est la course contre la montre
pour assurer le transfert de ses bagages
lorsque les escales sont trop courtes
il faut aller extraire les balises
jusque dans la soute
on va chercher les bagages en
correspondance par cdg et on les emmène
au total bien la peine de mort avant
l'aéroport de roissy charles de gaulle a
été taillée sur mesure pour air france
il est le seul en europe à pouvoir
encore se développer une quatrième piste
sera mise en service à la fin de l'année
un succès qui doit beaucoup à l'appui du
ministère des transports